good morning guys welcome to morning
coffee thoughts
um if you hear something snoring in the
background that's my dog
but today
um we are going to talk about
you know a couple critiques that the
haters have for me but before I start
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
ring that notification Bell that we are
going to be notified of my daily videos
and like the video on your way in so
um
a lot of people will say you don't have
to respond to the haters you don't have
to give us an explanation for any of
these things
however however
however I do because I think it's
entertaining
I think it's entertaining I think it
makes good content and my viewers seem
to just like like these so you know a
lot of times these are just responding
too
various
um you know things going on so
a recent critique of mine is that I saw
an opportunity
and I'm only doing this for money
whatever and it's a little offensive
because
I've always been good at things
now I've never been the smartest in the
room right I've never never will never
claim to be smart
I will never claim
to be like you know
super smarty pants whatever but I've
always worked hard and because I've
worked hard I've always Gotten Good at
things
um
and I think a lot of you can see my work
ethic like through the camera it's like
a compliment I've gotten I've Been Told
you're one of the hardest working
creators and I agree I really I think I
am I work very hard
um
because something my dad told me when I
was young
he said do what you love because when
you do what you love you're gonna put in
more hours than everyone else and you're
gonna be good at it
and that's the approach I've taken with
YouTube volleyball
um
really everything in life
um so I was in sales for two years I had
the best sales territory
um I really wasn't great at it at the
time but I
I could have got good like guys I was on
the cusp of greatness okay
because again I always start off
bad at things
and you can even see that with YouTube
like I had less subscribers than most
people do with my amount of videos at
first and I always start bad and then I
get good and that's just my life and
I was offered a pro contract this year
to go play pro volleyball
um which is kind of interesting I turned
down my my dream just people always ask
me like what's your dream job and I
always would have said sports or music
and so in a way I was I kind of turned
down my dream job
but that's because women's sports
doesn't pay a lot
um
but before I did men's Centric like the
manosphere men's content I actually
I went viral for so much stuff like I
had almost a million followers 80 were
female
um I did couples content back with my
ex-boyfriend I did
um
I almost lost the national TV for
relationship quizzes
um I I sorry my alarm went off
um I almost
or I I did house tour content I could
have just said a family vlog
y'all like that's what people don't
understand like
I'm me
and I don't say this to be cocky but I
just I figure things out and I get good
at things so this Narrative of
you saw an opportunity blah blah blah
it's like I see the world as opportunity
and I know that if I stayed in sales I
would have been good at that
I know that if I stayed and did Vlogs
with my family I would have been good at
that
my whole thing is I want to advocate for
men in an entertaining way
and a lot of people that criticize me
it's interesting because they have their
own YouTube channels and they'll go back
and forth about your intention to blah
blah blah blah blah and it's like then
why are you on YouTube
turn off and say those same people have
the monetizations on on your channel
it's like if you're not in it for the
money
turn off turn off your monetization turn
it off
don't make any money
do everything for free
um they don't like that too
and the same people that say oh I want
to have conversations facilitate
conversations whatever
bring people together you can do it off
of YouTube
you can do all the things that people
say I'm not in it for money
um I don't care I'm not a money guy
um don't care about money
um also the same people that say they
want to criticize me for trying to be
entertaining the only difference you can
do everything we do on YouTube you can
do it off of YouTube
and the only difference is you don't
have to do it in an entertaining way
so
um
yeah you know I to conclude this is to
conclude I would have been good at
anything
um I am delusional in the fact that I
think I can do anything and I know if I
stayed in sales I wouldn't on that I
almost had a million followers talking
to women so
yeah
um I I did not need this
there are a lot of niches that I could
have did I chose this one because I like
it
um
and two I turned down my dream job to do
this actually which is kind of funny
granted it was a low paying dream job
um there's not a lot of money in women's
sports but but it's funny because
someone asked me the other day what my
dream job would have been and for a
while I said two things I said either a
singer when I was like a kid kid when I
was a little bit older I said Sports and
I turned down my dream job to do this so
uh yeah that's that's my coffee thought
of the day uh like the video on your way
out subscribe to the channel I'll talk
to you next time